and your business you were window
cleaning so years ago first house how
much did you agree to buy it for 29 500
raised a bit of Finance for a loan which
then paid for the house you've now got a
house that's worth what 85 Grand how
much you're renting for five eight five
a month and what do you make a month
profit about 350 a month damn how many
problems have you got in total I've got
eight in total did you own any houses
before joining the academy no so in
seven years you're gonna have 84 Grand
so you're talking from one deal I could
have sold it and made three grand but
I've made 210 Grand so the government
and the banks are printing billions of
pounds if you can't get your hands on 29
Grand you need cheating it was 152.5
Grand purchase price currently cash flow
in about 5k a month passive income
that's like Financial Freedom from one
deal
so Scott how does it feel to be a
property millionaire oh it's fantastic
yeah it's amazing for um it's been a
good journey now Mary it's yeah better
than a Ford be so you started with
nothing yeah where did you grow up in
the council estate in Leicester called
as monso and now only your property
millionaire but you're also an author
yeah the best version of you what does
that mean so it just means yeah is is
starting from the bottom
um of like a personal development
journey and then becoming the best
version of you so yeah just getting the
best out of yourself so whether that's
work wise or personally or or with your
family is just just getting the best
version from yourself love that man so
when you started in property how did you
finance your first deal because it was
an incredible Little Peach of a house in
Grimsby could you talk me through how
you financed it and how you've now grown
that first little small house into an
Empire so yeah um I had no money at the
start so I found the deal and then I
raised a bit of Finance for a loan I got
15K and then I've got a joint venture
partner in on it and about a month
before I was going to complete they
dropped out but luckily at the time
there was all this coronavirus stuff and
it worked out really well for me because
I got a loan through my business which
then paid for the house and paid for a
bit of the refurb and got the money back
on the refinance and okay so in your
business you were what were you doing
window cleaning okay so your window
cleaning in Leicester yeah you decide
you want to build a property portfolio
and become and become a property
millionaire yeah this was only what two
years ago yes yes about yeah two years
ago two years ago first house how much
did you agree to buy it for and what was
the condition of the house so it was run
down a lady had passed away so it not
been refurbed in a long time and and the
purchase price was 29 500. 29 Grand but
you don't have the money to buy it still
no I still didn't
yeah bro yeah I literally calling all my
mates up when I got the deal accepted
and was like
do you want to go off so you got some
money or and everyone was like no no no
and then one of my mates was like yeah
and then like I say he went to
um a month before he went to buy his own
house and was like look I need to put
the money towards that I can't do it no
more so I was like [__] where am I gonna
get
the rest of the money but like I said
just just having faith and persisting
with it the money came out of thin air
and managed to buy it and well yeah
because you can get loans yeah I mean
when people say to me I can't afford to
get into property I'm like you might not
be able to afford it but the government
and the banks are printing billions of
pounds if you can't get your hands on 29
Grand you need shooting yeah yeah he's
like come on so you got a loan yeah how
much interest did you have to plan alone
I don't know exactly I think it's like
10 percent it shouldn't even be that
yeah it might even be less because at
the time the interest rates were we're
bottoming out so yeah but even 10 that's
quite a lot of money yeah so if you're
borrowing 29 Grand you have to pay 2 900
every year yeah back to the back to the
lender so you buy it for 29 Grand yeah
how much did you have to spend on it
about another 29 Grand so to be fair
because it's my first brr I made a few
little mistakes on it um which I've
learned from and obviously won't do it
in the future and really it should have
been about a 20K early 20K refurb yeah
it was a bit more learned from your
mistakes move on what we teach as you
know is we teach stock small and every
deal do bigger and bigger yeah because
if you start on your first project and
it's a piece of land and you're trying
to build 10 houses and you don't know
anything about property development
you've never done a refurb you don't
know how to handle project no because
you'll make mistakes yeah you always
make mistakes on your first projects I'd
rather make mistakes on a 29 grand house
yeah than on a 2.9 Million Pound
building site so you started small you
obviously had the support and the
mentoring of myself and the team yeah
you bought it for 29 you spent 29 Grand
on it one should refurbed it and how did
you get the money for the refurb so I
was literally working like seven days a
week so I'd go like I was I was doing
the refurb myself as well but um I was
like working seven days a week so I'd do
window clean clean in four days which
would bring me money in to pay for the
refurb and then go go up there for a few
days so yeah so you just sort of like
paid out of drips and drabs yeah what
you were saving and throwing your money
in I still had a little bit left for
credit cards and stuff like that so
literally by the end of it I was maxed
out on everything overdrafts credit
cards loans and I think if it had been
like another month
later of like getting finance and stuff
it would have been I went far off
thinking like how am I going to pay next
month's bills were like but but you now
push the value yeah yeah exactly you've
now got a house that's worth what 85
Grand yeah so now what did you do
presumably refinance refinance yeah talk
me through what does it mean to buy a
house refurb it and refinance it so
obviously yeah but you buy a house uh
below market value you refurb it to push
up the value and then you uh remortgage
it
um for a lender and they'll give you a
mortgage 75 of the new value so as long
as yeah you you've added value to the
property you can pull all your money out
sometimes so did you get back all those
all that savings all that money that
you've saved up yeah did you get all
that back most of it I left like 5K in
the deal so yeah pretty much all of it
and the loan that you took off of the
the business loan did you have enough to
pay that back yeah yeah I had enough to
pay pretty much everything back so
basically you ended up buying a house
for like five grand yeah and you rented
it out yeah how much you rent it for
five eight five a month and what do you
make a month profit about 350 a month
after all expenses on it so that was the
beginning of your Empire yeah when you
refinanced and pulled the money back
what did you then do with that money
that you you'd refinanced that money
went towards buying a bed and breakfast
in cleethorpes which is next to Grimm's
bet that's probably our best purchase so
far it was 152 and a half Grand purchase
price
um it's currently cash flowing uh
positive
about 5k a month passive income
yeah that's like Financial Freedom from
one deal yeah yeah sorry how much do you
pay for that house 152 and a half Grand
152 and a half why is that specific uh
because I negotiated down on it yeah
yeah
okay so you bought it for 152 and a half
Grand how much did you have to put in as
like a deposit and stuff about 35k and
you use the money that you got from the
refinance from the Grimsby house yeah
okay so you bought that you bought about
35 Grand in yeah did you push the value
up or was it already
um we've not actually like pushed the
value upon that so with what we've done
is just changed the the not the model
but it's still a bed and breakfast model
We Do It Room by room so um I see in the
video not long ago with Mo where it's
done like a hotel sort of thing and
that's how we're doing that so it's
making five grand a month like positive
cash flow but that's only 50 occupied
because it's in the winter it's in the
seaside town if we're getting in the
summer and it gets to 100 then it'll be
10 grand a month for making from it so
um yeah it's a really good deal and
that's kind of the reason I wanted to
get into brr's is because I know like
the deal sourcing your rental rents good
cash flow if you're deal sourcing you
sell a deal you make three grand whereas
like saving the first deal with just
explained then I've made 25 Grand from
the renovation
um it makes four grand a month
positive passive income over 25 years
for four grand times 25 that's 100 Grand
so then we're saying we've made 125
Grand already within the 25 years as
well it's going to double the price of
the house going to double very light
though so that's another 85 Grand so
you're talking from one deal that's 210
Grand you've made I could have sold it
and made three grand but I've made 210
Grand so that's kind of why I was like
right brr is the one for me that's where
I want to make all my money yeah and
then obviously talk about the clefox one
if we're getting a commercial valuation
on that it's probably worth about 600k
and brought it for 150 so in 18 months
time I could refinance
pull you know triple my money out and
and still making five grand a month it's
it's an amazing deal what did you buy
after cleethorpes I'm doing lease option
at the minute on uh four flats
so the refurb on that's been about 30k
so far
and it's going to be another 30k to do
the bottom flat and how many problems
have you got in total I've got eight in
total eight including the house we live
in yeah and you're doing a combination
of buying houses pushing the value up
refinancing that's by refurbatory
Finance yeah and then you're doing lease
option agreements yeah how are you
finding lease option agreements what
what is the lease option agreement a
lease option agreement is where you have
an agreed purchase price in a certain
amount of time so for instance like five
years and then you agree with the
landlord a rent amount each month as
well so literally one I'm working on
today I'm speaking to a landlord is 900
a month rent and we're giving him 200
grand for the house and that's what he
wants that's what it's on the market for
but in seven years time and then in the
meantime what we're going to do is HMO
it for about 500 a room it's five beds
so we'll we'll bring in about two and a
half K pay him is 900 a month make the
profit then the profit will accumulate
over time and we'll buy the house with
with the profit that we've made oh mate
I'm excited about what you've done yeah
you look amazing as well thank you so
how did you do this like what what's the
secret behind your success just hard
work determination is having belief in
yourself I know from the academy you get
the knowledge you which gives you the
belief and then it was like the first
deal it's like well I've learned this
stuff now I've got faith in Samuel faith
in the team I'm just going to go out
there and do it because there's a lot of
time where like negative thoughts pop in
and you're like is this actually going
to work is this house gonna you know
gonna work but just have faith belief
hard work with the academy and the
training is like the mindset it gives
you as well is like incredible you like
nothing phases me now I'll go out and
and I'll look at like even say half
million pound ass and I'd be like well
if it's good enough how can I raise the
money
and even like this we have raised 100
Grand towards deals which are in my
Pipeline and you know a few years ago
that would be like
I wouldn't have even thought of it or
wouldn't even like think that's possible
yeah so yeah it's crazy and also you've
successfully done deal sourcing you've
also done instruments yeah um you had a
a nice rent to rent which you decided
when covert happened to give the keys
back to but how much were you making on
that uh 600 a month profit and where was
it in Leicester and then you've also
deal selling like where what's the are
you like one of these guys I can imagine
you know passive deal seller so if you
find something that doesn't quite work
for you but it's still a good deal
you'll just pass it on to somebody else
and take a few grand yeah exactly yeah
I've got I'm compliant I've got a
company and everything and it's one of
them where like yeah if I stumble across
something that doesn't quite fit what I
do yeah let's see if you'll make a few
thousand yeah but a lot of people that's
got they'll flush deals down the drain
because they don't understand deal
selling so they'll go out they'll view a
couple properties it's like waiting for
a bus you know and you're waiting for a
bus and you'll be waiting half an hour
and then suddenly three buses come at
once and you're like ah yeah where were
you when I needed you I found in my
experience that when you're looking for
a deal you're looking for a deal like
three months you're waiting and you're
wait and then suddenly two three four
deals all come at once and most people
will take the best and leave the others
why not take the best and sell the
others yeah is that clear all right
Finance yeah true that's it that's what
I'm kind of getting now is like I'm
edging more towards raising the finance
because I'm I've got the deals I've got
the evidence to back it up that I can do
what I'm saying I'm doing I've got the
cash flow coming in
when when it's like raising Finance it's
like well it just makes sense because I
could sell the deal and make three grand
or I could buy the deal and make 200
Grand like yeah so I mean I'm thinking
let's just raise the fine but then there
is also the argument of fast pound
slowpan yeah yeah exactly buy refurbish
refinance is slow yeah and if you ain't
got cash coming in then you run out of
boxes in your business so you need to
sell some deals you need and you've got
your window cleaning of course which is
which is fast pound you've now got your
service accommodation your hotel
everything you've got also your book how
much you're selling this for 7.99 that's
selling for that's good man yeah I'm a
real life experience of somebody that
started doing nothing yeah is it on
Amazon it's on Amazon Scott Leons yeah
be the best for yourself get it on
Amazon get it get it get it get it so
how did you get the money to even join
the academy because you said you started
with nothing Council on the state yada
yada how did you join the academy the
academy is a big investment bro so the
first couple of grand I had in you know
one of them like helped to buy ice or
things those terrible Scouts yeah yeah
so I joined Docker a course that was a
couple of grand and then in the meantime
I um was like I need to join the academy
so so basically I just made it happen so
yeah credit cards overdrafts and put me
into a minus but now obviously it's
catapulted me on my property journey and
made me a property millionaire within a
few years so what did your family
girlfriend what did they think when you
went into debt and joined the academy
yeah well I didn't really tell anyone at
the time it was like have I made the
right decision I've spent a lot of money
and then um obviously as I started doing
more deals it's like oh yeah I did pay I
did pay x amount for the training and
then everyone's like well you know it's
worth it you look at what you're doing
look at like how far ahead you are of
everyone else that it's like where you
was a few years ago sometimes you have
to be careful who you speak to because
rather than telling everyone what you're
going to do because they'll just
sometimes hold you back poopy Dreams
yeah you just need to go do it yeah go
become a property millionaire and then
everyone will say I always believed in
you yeah that's true but if you tell
them I'm gonna do this and I'm gonna do
that then it's like no it's not gonna
work so you've done it you've become a
property millionaire and um what's
what's the what's your strongest reason
why what's your motivation motivation's
like
um because I'm from like a council
estate and like obviously poverty when I
was younger I always thought you know
when I get older I want the best for my
son I want the best for my family and I
want to provide for everyone as well
like my mum and dad have done everything
for me and then I want to give back to
them sort of now in terms of winter make
sure they don't have to work give the
best starting life for my son and
obviously ultimately live the best life
for me and my family so yeah that's my
why that's amazing bro what advice would
you give then to someone starting out in
property wanting to become a property
millionaire starting from nothing what
would you say my advice would be get
educated so invest in yourself like you
say numerous times invest in yourself
because you're the best asset you can
invest in the property is the second
best so invest in yourself invest in
your training surround yourself with the
right people just everything what the
academy brings is like it changes your
mindset it gets you to to hang around
successful people just just invest in
yourself I think when I first joined the
Academy I had no deals and I you know
everyone talk about deals I'm like [__]
I've got a I've got to start doing what
they're doing or I'm going to be left
behind and and so it kind of forces you
into getting deals and you're thinking
well if they can do it I can do it and
that's what I would say to everyone as
well is like if I can do it then you can
do it because I've started from nothing
I've built it up I've got to where I am
now and 100 anyone can do it because I
can remember for ages you were just the
Grimsby boy
I'm like dude you need some more deals
you can't just you know just keep
celebrating that one little house you've
done come on and now you've gone on to
become
did you own any houses before joining
the academy no no no
that's so cool how do you manage with
these bigger projects how do you manage
Builders because with biorefirmatory
Finance that's one of the trickiest part
knowing how much the refurb is going to
be finding the builders managing them
how do you how do you do that yeah so
that's kind of what the first house why
I worked on it a lot myself so I had an
idea of what the costs were and how long
it would take and stuff like that but
with managing Builders I would say
obviously have stage payments and don't
pay them too much upfront and just keep
on top of them just make sure you're
checking the job regularly and at least
I do mine probably at least worst case
once every two weeks but I like to be up
there once a week just to make sure that
it's going as as it should that I'm
paying for something that has been done
rather than they've said it's been done
plenty of phone calls plenty of
communication make sure the payments are
I always make sure that I pay them
properly as well like you know if it has
been done right pound properly on time
yes yeah reward them yeah and do what
you said you were going to do yeah if
you want the builders to do what they
said they were going to do then you have
to do what you said you were going to do
rather than just trying to be like how
can I find a good Builder no no how can
I be a good client to a builder yeah
because there's two ways yeah right I
also know not because we've spoken about
this but I just know for you to have
become a property millionaire from
nothing from zero to property
millionaire in the shortest Place time
you've had using biofurmacy Finance you
will have had some freaking nightmares
oh yeah because property is hard yeah
and buy with service refinance is hard
refinancing dealing with lenders and
Builders and buying properties is how it
takes forever to buy a house I've had
sites where I'm trying to get planning
permission for like three years
refinances title Deeds so talk to me a
little bit about patience within the
business yeah so you're going to need
patience so obviously you're going to
have to like the property going through
you're going to need patients like BNB
talk about a year to go through because
it's like probate and stuff but now
you're making five grand a month yeah
exactly but then it's worth it you know
what I mean so what have you got going
on at the moment then what deals have
you got going through at the moment or
things happening in the background so
yeah I've got a couple of lease options
going through at the moment
um I've got another bed and breakfast
going through and another HMO going
through so I've got a lot going through
lease options then how are you getting
landlords and sellers to agree to this
so one of them that's going through at
the moment is a wealthy guy who's got a
lot of properties in Grimsby Clee Fox
area and he's just um just wants to call
it a day wants to move abroad sell all
his houses and do it the most tax
efficiently way possible so with his HMO
is and we're going to give him 900 a
month
uh rent we're going to give him about
200 grand for the property which is what
it's on the market for now but in seven
years time and then rent each room out
at 500 pound a room and then we make the
profit so basically what we said to him
is like look we'll take the property off
your hands you're going to have a like a
sale down the line so you've not got to
worry about anything and then you can
just move abroad whenever you want and
you know that this house has taken care
taken care of and then obviously we've
kind of sold it as like any more
properties that you want to give us like
we'll make sure that we'll do a good job
so that you're happier and then any
other properties that you that you think
would match that sort of criteria that
we're giving you then we can do that
further down the line as well it's in
clear Forbes wow will you get 500 room
in cleethorpes yeah it's about 1 10 120
a week so um so yeah it's cheap area bro
it is cheap how much have you agreed to
buy it for in seven years 200 200 yeah
so how much profit will you make if
you're paying him 900 yeah and then
you're renting out room by over at how
many rooms five five yeah you're gonna
have to get a license and everything
it's already got one so how much profit
will you make a month so we've we've
said conservatively about about a grand
a month because we're gonna manage it
herself if you're getting a grand a
month for seven years yeah that's 12
Grand a year times seven that's 84 Grand
yeah so in seven years you're gonna have
84 Grand
yeah and a property which should have
gone up a lot in value and then you can
use the 84 Grand as you can use part of
that money as a deposit yeah buy the
property for 200 Grand problem with
people saving up for properties is by
the time you've saved up the deposit the
house is going to be value yeah but
you're fixing the price now yep
super smart man what's he been like
working with me oh it's been amazing
yeah it's been incredible it's um like I
said I've probably told you about 10
times like it's changed my life like
completely this time seven years ago I
was working like six pounds 70 an hour
and now we're talking about I'll do a
deal and make 200 Grand in a day so I
mean it's it's crazy like if if I knew
what I knew now then I'd have done it
years ago but yeah well mate you're
doing extremely well what do you want to
be remembered for
that's a good question
um I just want to be remembered for
giving back to people so like I said I
want to elevate people up so like I
think a lot of it at the minute and say
like you cancer States or deprived areas
is is people feel trapped so just to let
them know that you know that saving the
book it's just to look there's an idea
for you eight quid go and buy it see if
it changes something just one little
thing can change your life so hopefully
me showing people it can be done and
just elevating people up really is Adam
Brock is from a council of State yeah
what did you think of him winning the
eviction I think it's a nice guy I
really like Adam so I'm happy for him
and yeah I think he's a great guy what
was your experience of that month in the
eviction it was grueling yeah I mean
obviously I'm disappointed I went out
when I did I think you went out too
early yeah thank you but no I I've gone
into it and I've came out a better
person so it was it was worth it to me
do you believe anybody can be a property
millionaire
um yeah yes and no so if if you have the
the determination and hard work and you
uh invest in yourself and you and you
get the mindset then yeah but if you're
gonna mess about and you know treat it
as a as a side hustle or something then
no like just hit it hard and then yeah
anyone can do it well Scott massive
congrats on your success congrats on
your book as well bro I need you to sign
the copy for me yeah while you're here
well done really proud of you I hope you
guys enjoyed the video get a copy of
Scott's book Scott Leon's the be the
best version of you it's on Amazon also
come down meet me let's do some training
how much do you cost to get started at a
crash course Scott one pound one pound
one pound that's where Scott get started
what would you say someone thinking
about coming to the crash course do it
do it 100 do it or change everything one
pound change your financial life forever
I'll leave a link in the description
come meet me find the city nearest to
yourself if dates are available they
sell out faster get booked on now and we
will see you next time
[Music]
thank you